bonjour merci d'être avec nous on dirait
que sur arte france alors deux faits
distingue partis de l'opposition qui
dénonce souvent les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle et puces coup
d'état militaire de cette semaine qui a
été déjoué
la crise politique au niger est ce qu'on
est en train de s'y approcher
dangereusement la crise politique lui
elle est effective elle et d'effectifs
bv nigériens vivent à ce moment précis
je dirais un événement historique
l événement historique parce que depuis
1960 l'indépendance c'est la première
pour qu'on assiste à une transition
démocratique et mélo béni vit sous haute
tension
l'instabilité ramener des vagues de
contestations et les résultats proclamés
par la commission électorale et validés
par la cour constitutionnelle ont
véritablement créé une situation qui est
restée très tendue vous le disions c'est
la première transition démocratique
depuis l'indépendance du niger ont
beaucoup de coups d'état depuis que
sait-on sur le coup d'état de mardi soir
justement au fait de ces des traditions
ou au niger
no good était devenu pratiquement une
institution c'est à dire lorsque
électorat noste la scène politique est
bloquée lorsque le gouvernement et les
oppositions ne parviennent par à 50 pour
préserver la paix l'armée s'est toujours
présenté comme étant gokhran
d'institutions étatiques ne parle au
passé on a assisté à de telles
intrusions suit la scène politique et
des périodes de transition quasi
interminables et compte tenu de la
situation que l'on vit depuis
pratiquement la proclamation ou alors
des piles au second tour était pénible
21 février et la proclamation des
résultats par la suite nos pays vit sous
tension tensions entre les deux parties
à savoir la partie qu'il a remporté
monsieur marc mais deux personnes et de
l'autre côté et trop man ancien
président de la république et qui n'a
pas connu la victoire fait d'émotions
parce c'est en face à cette situation
que l'armée comme d habitude a voulu
intervenir ne peut-être joué le rôle d
arbitre alors beaucoup dangereux pour le
nouveau président au delà de l'aspect
politique la réduction de la pauvreté
les indicateurs sociaux sont très
mauvais au niger quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre de mohamed raison pour changer
la donne la magie des manoeuvres de
monsieur 20 sous elle tient compte fait
d'un certain nombre de considérations
vous savez dans le cadre du second tour
il est bien lourd et c'est pratiquement
plié au premier tour avec 39 % des
suffrages exprimés contre 16 pour son
concurrent japon son adversaire dans le
cadre du second tour il a dû rallier les
deux principales réserves d eau pour des
devoirs savoir les voix de monsieur
seyni oumarou qui était qui a vu qui a
quand même eu quelques 8 % au premier
tour et monsieur avoue bac et venir avec
7% ou obtenir tout cela suppose en fait
un jeu d'alliances mais aussi
inspectez équilibre dans l'eau pouvoir
dans la façon même d'appréhender nos
pouvoirs et dirigé de diviser nos défis
mais au-delà de cet aspect il convient
de soutenir que la magie de manoeuvre
elle tient compte de la capacité
programme sur gazon pour élever des
défis du pays que vous aviez un terrain
tout souligné terry d'oeuvre sécurité la
prise est la prise et sécurité dans nos
styles en libye et dans le bassin du lac
tchad
concrètement il est question de faire
face aux différents que tendance et
d'élégance la ligue dans le sahara et en
afrique de l'ouest
léon congo merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et spécialiste des relations
internationales merci à vous